welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
first three episodes of the boys
spin-off gen V this takes place between
seasons 3 and the upcoming season 4 of
the boys on Amazon Prime video it's set
in the same universe and this show is so
good it's packed with Easter eggs fun
details and lots of blood and yeah we're
going to break down the biggest stuff
that you might have missed from these
first three episodes and if you're not
as familiar with what the show is we did
do a primer video with everything you
need to know going into this series
including the tie-ins to the boys and
really everything you need to know about
the boys be sure to check that out if
you haven't seen it already but let's
talk about these first three episodes of
gen V and this video was sponsored by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform that
makes launching your own website of
Breeze episode one God you this title is
an affectionate abbreviated nickname for
gulan University the college for
superheroes where most of the series
takes place the name of the University
actually comes from the boys comic
storyline that was also pretty messed up
to say the least this series draws
inspiration from it but it's mostly its
own creation we open on a vssn news clip
that's vot Sports Network about a train
joining the seven this is about 8 years
prior to where we are now and meline
still will Elizabeth Shu hasn't had her
brain melted by homelander yet at train
is the first black member of the seven
which is why this family is watching
which proves what we have been saying
for a long time we live in a postracism
world still well and Bot never miss an
opportunity to Pat themselves on the
back like this in just hilariously gross
and misguided ways we get a shot at VA
Tower before it was destroyed by soldier
boy in season 3 of the boys there's also
a shot of the current lineup of the
seven from left to right it's
Lamplighter the Deep Queen mave
homelander black moir a train and
translucent a lot of them have since
died in some gruesome ways the news
ticker on the bottom reads want to
bootstrap themselves out of poverty so
vot News network is pretty right-wing
and everything it reports on benefits
the vot corporation in some way the
ticker continues with a quote from
Professor Richard Brink bierhoff he's
the crime fighting department chair at
gulan University played by Clancy Brown
the quote reads Brinker off at Tran came
to me so naturally gifted but growing up
without a father figure he'll be the
first to tell you I filled that void for
him kept him out of trouble healthy diet
clean living got him to hone his
something which clean living ironic
considering atrian will get addicted to
compound V we cut to the living room of
the morose a black family watching this
news broadcast the dad is so excited to
see the first black man inducted into
the seven but his pre-teen daughters
Marie and Annabeth are just too busy
with their phones to care they're
recreating the 2015 photo from Kendall
Jenner's Instagram which at the time was
the most liked photo in Instagram
history the mom is similarly unimpressed
with they train he goes clubbing with
Jake Paul and Scott D I will take
whatever I can get Jake Paul a YouTuber
turn fcker who's had a share of
controversies please don't fight me Jake
and Scotty you know the socialite who
has had three kids with Courtney
Kardashian and is mostly known for being
rich at train partying with these guys
it's a fun contrast to the narrative VA
is pushing that he's a down toe poor kid
from the streets Marie the older of the
two daughters gets cramps from her first
period And there's a big big painting of
flowers on the wall right next to her a
metaphor you could say for her flowering
to a woman but it's not a pretty picture
on the TV we hear I'll always protect
you you're a little hero this is
actually from the cuddle buddies
commercial that we saw in the boys
featuring the junior homelander Cuddle
Buddy doll that was later used to
smuggle fenel marray gets her period and
unfortunately that's when her powers
manifest she has the ability to
manipulate blood but she has no clue
what is happening here it ends up
accidentally killing both her parents r
he and the idea of superpowers Dawning
at the moment of someone's puberty is
really just something that goes all the
way back to X-Men Comics specifically
the 2000 X-Men movies where the pesent
Rogue has her powers awaken in just the
worst possible moment the worst possible
way okay cut to present day Marie now
played by Jazz Sinclair jolts awake in
bed as if she was dreaming about
everything we just saw Megan the
stallions anxiety plays and Maria is
waiting to hear if she got into gulan
University so her day is filled with
anxiety one teen in her shared room
floats above a bed as they sleep Maria
has posters of Queen Ma and Golden Boy
on her wall along with a motivational
bring her off calendar with today's date
circled in blood red and 4 p.m. written
on it we also see a sign for the Red
River Institute under video surveillance
24 hours a day Marie was sent here after
her parents' death it's like a juvenile
facility for the soups we actually saw a
photo of Marie Moro as being at the Red
River facility in season 3 of the boys
then at group therapy this guy says
since Starlight left the seven I've just
been inspired to speak my own Truth at
the end of season the boys Starlight
burned her superhero outfit and
officially joined up with huie and
Butcher and the rest of the Vigilantes
Marie reads the hero inside of all of us
one of brinkerhoff's books it's heavily
highlighted and marked up so this guy's
clearly someone she looks up to she cuts
her Palms with a switchblade to practice
her blood powers and we see previous
scars indicating that she's done this a
lot I think one of the most fascinating
things about the show is the way that it
uses things like bulimia and cutting as
kind of like a dark way to one
superpowers here we see her leaving a
literal river of red around the the Red
River Institute Insignia on the floor
that also has the year The Institute was
established 1965 we later learned this
was the same year gulan was founded
uhhuh at the end of the training session
Marie has to sit down because yeah
losing that much blood has got to make
you woozy she sees a fellow student get
carted off by armed guards to the Elmyra
adult rehabilitation center by global
Wellness Services a vot company of
course this is another institution owned
by vot where soups that turn 18 and
don't get adopted are sent we hear from
Marie school counselor that this
facility is much worse than Red River
now the counselor is Vanessa who we saw
in season 3 of the boys when huie was
investigating Victoria Newman's
upbringing at Red River Global Wellness
Services is a shell company that
provides Therapy Services for Soups the
red-handed kid at the library is
watching home Banger red white and anal
a homelander spoof porn that originally
appeared in season 2 of the boys Marie
gets accepted into gulan and tells her
counselor that she's going to be the
first black woman in the seven we get
this hilarious God view orientation
video Eric kky regular Alexander Calbert
who played Jack on Supernatural plays
Rufus one of the students giving a
testimonial kryy created the boys and
serves as an executive producer on genv
the dean of students is indiretti she
explains that there are two tracks for
God you students the Crimson countis
school for the Performing Arts or The
Lamplighter school for crime fighting
there's this statue of Lamplighter and I
love how the camera pans just enough so
that the sun glare makes it look like
he's holding a ball of fire because his
power was fire manipulation and stands
in front of the stained glass window
which shows homelander Queen mave
Lamplighter a train Crimson count in the
top row is kind of hard to see but it
looks like maybe Starlight polarity whom
we'll meet later and translucent or
possibly black noir the mural on the
ceiling is similar to one in vot Tower
but with a new blue sky around the edges
and lamp lighter is back after being
removed from the vot mural to make room
for Starlight and kryy confirmed that
Starlight is actually gone from the vot
tower version in the boys season 4 we
learned that Queen Ma and at Tran both
attended godu and were ranked number one
and the Deep was ranked number six which
is just hilarious he's such a doofus
being in the top 10 10 is a big deal and
it basically guarantees you great
endorsements entry into the seven or
some other huge perks so it's highly
competitive the current top three are
shown Luke Rearden number one Jordan Lee
number two and Andre Anderson number
three another mural in the student
commment shows Queen ma someone in green
who I think we haven't seen yet a train
black Mar Crimson Countess polarity
Lamplighter translucent the Deep
Starlight and homelander as Maria
arrives at school we hear the Donna's
cover version of Billy Idols Dancing
with Myself there are soup statues lined
in the campus but one appears to be
missing it seems most likely that this
is Soldier Boy since he was disgraced at
the end of season 3 for attacking the
other soups and destroying vot Tower
Marie walks through the machine that
looks like a metal detector but you know
it would be kind of silly to have it a
school for superheroes so I think we'll
find out later that this serves some
other purpose the ra is Maverick the
invisible guy that we saw in the
orientation video and he's telling the
students about a mandatory consent
seminar one student asks if his penis is
out and he says yes because as
established by translucent soups with
that power can just make themselves
invisible but not their clothes so they
usually just go go naked fought News
Network breaking news report says that
jury selection begins today for the
trial of homelander so at the end of
season 3 of the boys he killed a
protester on live TV vnn is spinning it
with a headline Reading New Evidence
Russia plotted seven Tower attack
homelander lawyer he stood his ground
make a that one you will a social media
poll from liil Miss activists asking for
honest thoughts on vot continuing after
Ma's apparent death has these options it
honors her Legacy don't care she's dead
what does she care let's pressure them
to remove her products I bought a second
freezer to hoard the lasagna the
background for the poll is a box of
Brave mes vegetarian Pride lasagna with
Ma on the cover next to a rainbow then
there's an autographed May Funko Pop
selling on vay the vot version of eBay
for $1900 we meet Marie's roommate Emma
Meyer AKA Little Cricket and her Geral
David Caruso Emma can make herself small
and in her room there's a little
wardrobe with all her little clothes
Marie asks who's David Caruso you didn't
see Jade just hilarious at the 19 95
film is Emma's go-to Caruso example not
CSI Miami but you know that's a joke and
it's a good one Emma has a mini cutout
of Starlight and a redesign superhero
costume from when vot wanted to make her
sexier the roommates go watch Luke
reared in AKA Golden Boy his training
session he's played by Patrick
Schwarzenegger and yes that's Arnold's
kid also the kid of Maria Shriver so
he's like technically a Kennedy and on
the show seems to be affected by a kind
of meta Kennedy curse he has human
torch-like powers and can engulf himself
in thermal energy setting himself a BL
his girlfriend is Kate Dunlap a mind
empath who can push thoughts onto people
to make them go do stuff kind of like
kill grave from the Marvel Universe
Andre Anderson is his best friend and he
can manipulate metal like Magneto can
Marie meets Jordan Lee played by two
different actors who has the ability to
switch genders it seems like each
version of Jordan has a different
ability because when Brink shoots them
they switch from male to female so the
male at least is invulnerable but we'll
talk more about their powers as we go
Brink tells Golden Boy that he's been
accepted into the seven who who are
likely looking for someone to replace
homelander as the All-American and
vulnerable face of the group homelander
statue you notice has graffiti on it
that says Rock which could just be some
soups signature tag we'll later see some
maintenance guys cleaning this off Emma
reads through the comments in her latest
episode of her YouTube show Fun Size
with Little Cricket and folks this is
why you never read the comments except
except you in the comments of this video
I'll read your comments cuz I love you
all but in general it's a hellscape that
we YouTubers try to avoid at all costs
and yeah there is a scene where shrinks
down to help a guy get over his um
complex one might say it's an insane
scene but you know at least not as
graphic as what termite did to that guy
using similar abilities at the bar Andre
uses his powers to impress a woman he's
hitting on and he turns a coin into a
little metal hummingbird he gets bumped
by someone who loses control of the bird
which slices through a woman's neck
Marie saves her life by forcing the
blood back into her body mids spurt and
closing up the wound and on a show as
bloody as the boys is folks this is a
pretty big game changer this whole
ordeal is caught on people's camera
phones and Marie becomes a minor
celebrity she's rewarded for it by
getting kicked out of school by Brink he
wants her to take the fall for Andre and
the others this mirrors starlight's
Journey on the seven when she was also
caught on camera saving a woman and
almost got fired for this we see this
extra in a green sweater with white
streaks on her hair and she kind of
looks like Rogue from X-Men which
knowing the boys and Eric kpy is
probably intentional Marie storms down
the hall to Brink's office and she's
wearing a maroon leather trench coat
that was designed as an homage to
butcher's trench coat after catches Luke
murdering Brink he goes after her but
Jordan steps in and we get a good
oldfashioned sup fight and a better look
at Jordan's Powers as Luke flames on
Jordan switches to the male Persona to
avoid the damage then they switch to the
female Persona to throw a punch that it
looks like they're using some kind of
energy Shield to pack an extra wallp
then they actually materialize another
energy blast to throw at Luke outside
Jeff godu social media director tries to
get Andre to do an ad for Turbo Rush
remember that's a trains energy drink
after Luke runs outside he whispers
something to Andre and then flies up
high in the air to make himself so fiery
that he blows up from the inside
similarly in the boys Lamplighter who
could control fire but couldn't make it
himself he had to rely on outside
sources committed suicide by setting
himself a blaze inside bot Tower so at
the end of episode one we get a special
message from a familiar face Ashley
Barrett who is appointed CEO of VOD
after Stan Edgar got the boot she calls
Golden Boy death an isolated incident of
course she does and we get the coming
attractions for the season but since we
already know what's coming let's dive
into episode two if you're looking for a
more professional way to Showcase what
you do online than links to your social
media Pages it might be time to get
yourself a website and that means it's
time to check out Squarespace
Squarespace is an all-in-one platform
that provides you with everything you
need to do whatever you need with your
website Squarespace has templates and
designs for pretty much everything so
even if you're making your very first
website using Squarespace makes it super
easy to customize your look update
content and add features to fit your
unique needs for instance Squarespace
makes it easy to sell merch you can
design your products and then save time
and money by letting Squarespace handle
production inventory and shipping and if
you're selling any other kind of
physical Goods digital Goods or even a
service Squarespace makes it easy to
build your storefront and grow your
business to check it out for yourself
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a domain episode two it starts out
with Phoebe bridger's cover of Metallica
As Nothing Else Matters as Luke's
remains are cleaned up on campus
assigned for a cartoon black noir reads
no look lose this area patrolled by
security cartoon blackm have we learned
nothing from Boys season 3 that's where
the darkest things happen to blackm
despite this there is a lot of looking
lose though with everyone's got their
camera phones out the scooping up of
blown up bissa is reminiscent of episode
three of the boys which starts with
Butcher and Frenchie shoveling
translucent blown up remains into
similar buckets Ashley works from bot
Tower which is undergoing Renovations
she yells at Dean Shetty and polarity
who is Andre's dad played by Sha Patrick
Thomas from Save the Last Dance about
this golden boy incident Shetty says V
hired me because I'm a Problem Solver
when 400 kids learned they weren't gifts
from God but their parents drugged them
with compound V his infants I barely had
any suicides did I in the boys everyone
initially thought soups were born
randomly with vot and others pushing the
narrative that they were chosen by God
but then it was discovered that they
were all actually given compound v as
babies usually with their parents'
consent Emma wears a Nirvana sweatshirt
in between this and David Caruso kind of
seems like she's big in the '90s even
though she was definitely born after the
'90s if we assuming present day that's
okay I was a ' 90s kid I was obsessed
with the 80s now the jacket Jordan is
wearing has a KOMU or dog lion and a
falcon on the front and a map of Japan
on the back Rufus here is looking very
Maga in that red cap yeah it says keep
America safe and he's talking crap about
Kate so she uses her powers to make him
hit himself in the nuts with a baseball
bat while yelling Jumanji we actually
get to see this later in the episode
janji This Moment is kind of like when
Silver Fox Forest Striker to walk until
his feet bled and X-Men Origins
Wolverine her power are very similars to
Kate and Kate's eye has a verse blood
vessel in it so clearly this ability
takes a toll it kind of reminds me of
the weird eyes of Jason striker in X2
X-Men United who as kind of a mastermind
type figure has the ability to
manipulate people's free will like this
clearly a lot of Inspirations along with
killgrave are worked in here now we see
the new rankings Andre is number one
Daddy's thrilled Marie has jumped to
number eight the first freshman to crack
the top eight and Jordan has been bumped
to number five since it seems only Brink
was willing to overlook the fact that
their powers don't play well into the
vot demo actually later Jordan mentions
Jacksonville Florida which is my
hometown and I would have thought
Jacksonville has come a long way since
getting a lot of airtime on the good
place but you know Jacksonville's
Jacksonville I love it home place to
Leonard Skinner shout out to the 904 du
anyway so social media director Jeff
hooks Marie up with a number of vot tech
products this is for you for me when you
get back to your room you will find a
vpad vpod vods and vtif speakers and a
vbrator personal massager yeah the show
obviously poking funed apples branding
Jackie tone is back as courtne bot's
unscripted producer from season one of
the boys now EP in charge of Marie's
interview with Haley Miller another
character returning from the boys
polarity shows courtne a picture of
himself when he was his son's age in his
superhero uniform to prove that Andre is
a chip off the old block but it makes
sense why in episode one Andre said he
didn't want to be top ranked at the
school he's under a lot of pressure from
his dad it's interesting how all the
soups on the show have powers that are
tied to ya issues that teens struggle
with like Maria has to cut herself user
Powers Emma has to throw up to make
herself small Jordan's Powers deal with
issues around gender identity Kate tells
people what to do despite the fact that
it harms her kind of like modern
influencers and Andre has superpowers
like his dad and has to deal with
superpowered parental expectations
polarity says that after Andre's mother
died he wanted to crawl into a bottle of
maon maon 25 was the Whiskey sitwell
offered Senator Calhoun when she was
trying to win his vote to put soups in
the military in season one of the boys
vot is pushing the narrative that Marie
and Andre had fought and stopped Golden
Boy you guys are heroes So currently
we're testing the Guardians of gulan
even even when I'm saying it now it
feels like it's too many syllables so
we'll obviously a reference to Guardians
of the Galaxy which has one more
syllable we get another boys Cameo this
time from PJ burn playing Adam Bor
director of the vot studios film Dawn at
the seven he's a guest Professor for one
of the acting classes at gulan and still
very full of himself we learned that he
has to take this job from being in
director jail after exposing himself to
Minka Kelly which is just kind of
interesting for the show to do because
they also shout out Brian Singer I'm so
glad they made that joke also we see how
his whiteboard is filled with
pretentious quotes from Aristotle n
Oscar wild Plato plutar times of coinus
Napoleon and Shakespeare's quote all the
worlds of stage which yes totally
reflects the way VA uses superheroes to
push these false narratives we never
really know when something's a
theatrical performance or real life Dean
Shetty tells the school of crime
fighting students that she'll be taking
over Professor Brink's classes and she
stands in front of various TV screens
with a bunch of different information on
them one is an image of a human skull
another with a brand marketing style
words on it like stable forecast
Visionary and time frame there's a
series of news Clips as the TV switches
through some channels a presidential
campaign video for Robert Singer and his
vice presidential run running mate
Victoria Newman both of them from the
boys an update about homelanders trial
and then a vot News Network bit about
Luke's parents painting them in a
negative light they're being focused on
the way the parents of mass Shooters are
sometimes put in the media Spotlight
Emma and Justine smoke weed out of a
queen mave bong while debating what
scene to do for their acting class they
looked through a Netflix style queue of
vot movies dawn of the S big crazy love
big Crazy Love 2 a poster that Emma also
has on her wall and we see the
description of this one along the side
there stating termite is ated again
termite is another soup with shrink
Powers who you know had a pretty
unfortunate mishap on the boys involving
a guy's beus who met his own unfortunate
end from homelander in season 3 of the
boys there's also big heart pocket
romance Little Hero a queen made solo
film Nubian Prince that was the soup
sitwell was going to send to protect
Baltimore and the boys smallest heart
terminal beauty that one starring pop
claw that was a train's girlfriend whom
he killed with a heroin overdose in
season 1 and Rising tide which is the
Deep Solo movie Justine says those are
all termites movies oh that guy I went
to these huge parties you throw with
Brian Singer in the Hollywood Hills that
was gross yeah I did get the X-Men
director who has had a number of
allegations against him and if you
watched a deep dive investigation I did
about why we still haven't seen X-Men in
the MCU I really just think it's because
that guy is still a legacy producer on
any movie that has X-Men in the title
Luke's Brother Sam is being held in a
secret facility underneath the school
called the woods and they seem to be
doing medical experiments on him one
that looks like their harvesting spinal
fluid this could be related to v24 or
temp V the serum that was introduced in
the boy season 3 that gives regular
people superpowers for a limited time it
was highly toxic and unstable but if vot
could perfect it they could make
billions we'll see if this is related to
that or if it's something else entirely
as Emma learns that Justine spilled her
secret about her having to throw up to
use her powers to get small there's a
banner hanging with a picture of crimson
CEST that reads welcome freshman supers
momento adere simper which is Latin for
remember to always dare we find out that
soups have a wider range of hearing than
non-powered people do so one of the ways
they can be hurt is with these
highfrequency devices that security uses
on them Kate overd does it with her
power and she has a seizure and we end
the episode with Venus from Banana Rama
playing over the credits and then onto
episode three think Brink we opened 3
years ago on the sage Grove Center
psychiatric hospital this is the vot
subsidiary hospital that experiments on
soups that we saw in the boys also in
one of these rooms there is a you know
an x-rated Cameo of a certain hero named
love sausage who showed up at the
herogasm party in the boy season 3
Luke's Brother Sam was a patient there
and he just found out that his powers
don't come naturally his parents had the
brothers dosed with compound V when they
were babies so Emma we see has made
herself as small as an ant and then
reegs by eating a brave mave Pride bar
after homelander outed mave as a lesbian
on national TV vot really just
capitalized on it in the Gross Way only
huge corporations are capable of Dean
Chetty is laying it on thick with Marie
to get her to warm up to her making her
smiley face chocolate chip pancakes and
telling her she's proud of her Chetty
mentions she had a daughter so I'm
curious to see the backstory on that I'm
sure we'll get there in the quad there's
a missing poster for someone named Ron
Layman this is a janitor who had his
throat slid in episode 2 he's described
as a dog lover Grill Master and gentle
soul when Jordan is in the female
Persona in their room having sex salt
and peppers what a man plays and then
Jordan shifts into their male Persona
after their parents knock on the door
and I just love that when the guy Jordan
was with ph is naked through the dorm
room wall if you listen closely you can
hear the shout from whoever lives next
door Jordan's mom brings them bot a
burger including Deep's calamari poppers
considering deep can talk to sea
creatures it's just one messed up
endorsement and you know he wasn't happy
to do it he just kind of had to do it
the way homelander made him eat one of
his friends recently we learned the
board is voting on new school rankings
tomorrow so everyone goes to the brink
fundraiser event to suck up to them
there's a silent auction with a bunch of
merch the deeps Memoir deeper which we
saw him struggling to write in season
one of the boys a complete set of
Vitality beauty products and a pair of
signed a trainer sneakers based on a
trains durable Famous Footwear Marie
wears a red gown and these ruby earrings
that look like drops of blood dripping
down from her ear ears setting up the
bloody ears that we see at the end of
this episode you could say we see all
kinds of agents and lawyers approaching
Marie including one with this QR code
that I scanned and when I watched this
it took me to a tweet of Kate McKinnon
holding a UFC QR code in a 2021 SNL
sketch I don't know I think the code
might just be peral link online but who
knows by the time you're watching this
breakdown Amazon may have like updated
it into something else at Andre's
request Emma shrinks down and breaks
into the woods and we see this orderly
with a bandage on her left arm that
looks like a burn and she opens the
feeding door for a soup that immediately
shoots fire so you know that's how she
got it Emma sneaks into Sam's room on
the food tray and he has a poster on the
wall for payback that's a soup team led
by soldier boy in the past in another
poster of black noir Sam traps Emma
under a plastic cup exactly like you do
if you'd find a cricket in your house
the Deep gives a statement for the in
memorium video for brink brink didn't
just tone my skills he sharpened my mind
he turned me into the
Curious intelligent man I am today deep
pauses before the word intelligent and
Chase Crawford is just so good in this
role he plays him like a true ID idiot
there is this hilarious exchange between
Sam and Emma where Sam wants her to
prove that she's real and not just a
figment of his imagination what's the
name of my alltime favorite movie well
you're a white guy
so Godfather Star Wars or shash
shank Water World yeah who knows when
the last time was that Sam was actually
allowed to see a movie so maybe water
world was the last one or something but
between this and Emma's love for the
movie Jade these two are just made for
each other the guards discovered that
Emma is in the woods and they shock the
hell out of Sam by electrifying the
floor which is kind of something we saw
in narina 5 in Star Wars Andor so Emma
dives into this dude's ear and crawls
through his brain killing him in the
gruesome fashion that fans of the boys
have come to expect now from a practical
production standpoint the ear that Emma
crawls out of was built practically and
stood about 15 ft tall and had 1,000
gallons of fake blood in it and the boys
and genv get a lot of well-earned credit
for their amazing VFX work but like any
great VFX work what makes it so good is
the amount of effort they put into the
Practical special effects and it's where
we end episode 3 and it's just such an
incredible image okay yeah we kind of
condensed the first three episodes of
the boys in this one breakdown but let
us know in the comments if you're
excited about the show and if you want
us to keep breaking it down we're going
to try to keep up with Episode by
episode because this show again is so
good huge thanks to Gina apilo for
writing this breakdown and for Brandon
bar for all of his help with the
research as well please subscribe to new
rock stars and the Deep dive and the
breakroom and you can support this
network by grabbing some merch at nerd
r. shop you follow me at eaos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching
[Music]
bye